are you on the dating apps are you  trying any of that Ryan am I on the  dating apps I don't think I'm asking my  assistant no I I not that I know of no  no I don't think so how do you meet  people this is my problem this is why  I've not had covet either oh yeah yeah  but can you go to like a bar and sit  there and no bars I get really boring I  I mean when I'm I'm in a bar I start  using props because I just just sitting  around waiting for something to happen I  think that I tend to this is why  actresses date actors because you're  involved in something so sometimes it's  political or travel or whatever and  that's what I'm attracted to somebody  who's involved and passionate about  whatever they're involved in but not  trying to just pick you up and ask you  what your favorite color is and where  you work and whatever so that's  um that's never worked for me